¿Cómo podrían hacer hallazgos científicos sobre mis genes
si ponía mi identidad social como mujer negra?
Después de todo, me considero una mujer negra de padre blanco
en lugar de una mujer blanca de madre negra
debido completamente a razones sociales.
La identidad racial que marco
no tiene nada que ver con mis genes.
Bueno, a pesar de la importancia obvia de esta pregunta
para la validez científica del estudio,
me dijeron: "No te preocupes por eso,
solo pon lo que te identifique".
Así que marqué "negra",
pero no confiaba en los resultados de un estudio
que trataba a una variable tan crucial de manera tan poco científica.
Esa experiencia personal con el uso de la raza en pruebas genéticas
me hizo pensar:
¿En qué otro ámbito de la medicina se usa la raza
para hacer falsas predicciones biológicas?
Bueno, encontré que la raza cala hondo en toda la práctica médica.
Conforma diagnósticos médicos,
mediciones, tratamientos,
recetas,
incluso la propia definición de enfermedades.
Y cuanto más descubría, más me perturbaba.
Los sociólogos como yo han explicado extensamente
que la raza es una construcción social.
Cuando identificamos a la gente como negra, blanca, asiática, aborigen, latina,
nos referimos a grupos sociales
con delimitaciones inventadas que han cambiado con el tiempo
y varían en todo el mundo.
Como jurista también he estudiado
cómo los legisladores, no los biólogos,
han inventado definiciones legales de raza.
No es solo la visión de los científicos sociales.
¿Recuerdan cuando se presentó el mapa del genoma humano
en la Casa Blanca, en la ceremonia de junio de 2000?
El presidente Bill Clinton dijo la célebre frase:
"Creo que una de las grandes verdades
que surgen de esta expedición triunfal
al interior del genoma humano
es decir que, en términos genéticos,
los seres humanos, independientemente de la raza,
somos en más de un 99,9 % lo mismo".
Y podría haber agregado
que esa diferencia de menos de 1 %
no cae en las casillas raciales.
Francis Collins, que dirigió el proyecto Genoma Humano
y ahora dirige el NIH,
parafraseó al presidente Clinton:
"Estoy feliz de que hoy
hablemos de una única raza, la raza humana".
Los médicos se supone que deben practicar la medicina basada en evidencia,
y se los llama cada vez a sumarse a la revolución genómica.
Pero su costumbre de tratar pacientes por la raza está muy por detrás.
Tomemos la estimación
de la tasa de filtración glomerular, o TFG.
Los médicos habitualmente interpretan la TFG,
este indicador importante de la función renal, por la raza.
Como pueden ver en esta prueba de laboratorio,
exactamente el mismo nivel de creatinina,
la concentración en la sangre del paciente,
produce de forma automática una estimación de la TFG diferente
en función de si el paciente es afroestadounidense o no.
¿Por qué?
Me han dicho que tiene base en la suposición
de que los afroestadounidenses tienen más masa muscular
que las personas de otras razas.
Pero ¿qué sentido tiene
para un médico suponer automáticamente
que yo tengo más masa muscular que esa mujer fisicoculturista?
¿No sería mucho más preciso y basado en evidencia
determinar la masa muscular de cada paciente
sencillamente examinándolos?
Bueno, los médicos me dicen que usan la raza como un atajo.
Es un intermediario crudo pero conveniente
para factores más importantes como la masa muscular,
el nivel de enzimas, los rasgos genéticos
que simplemente no tienen tiempo para buscar.
Pero la raza es un mal intermediario.
En muchos casos, la raza no aporta información relevante en absoluto.
Es solo una distracción.
Pero la raza también suele abrumar las mediciones clínicas.
Ciega a los médicos de los síntomas de los pacientes,
de enfermedades familiares,
de su historia, de las propias enfermedades que podrían tener...
todo con más fundamento en evidencia que la raza del paciente.
La raza no puede sustituir estas mediciones clínicas importantes
sin sacrificar el bienestar del paciente.
Los médicos me dicen que la raza es solo uno de muchos factores
que tienen en cuenta,
pero hay numerosas pruebas médicas,
como la TFG,
que usan la raza de manera categórica
para tratar pacientes negros, blancos, asiáticos, de manera diferente
solo por su raza.
La medicina racial expone también a los pacientes de color
a sesgos y estereotipos dañinos.
Los pacientes negros y latinos tienen el doble de probabilidad
de no recibir calmantes que los blancos
por las mismas fracturas dolorosas de huesos largos,
por causa del estereotipo
de que las personas negras y marrones sienten menos dolor,
exageran su dolor,
y tienen predisposición a la adicción a fármacos.
La Administración de Alimentos y Drogas aprobó un fármaco específico para la raza.
Es una píldora llamada BiDil
para tratar la insuficiencia cardíaca en pacientes autoidentificados como afro.
Un cardiólogo desarrolló el fármaco sin distinción genética o de raza,
pero se volvió conveniente
por razones comerciales
comercializar el medicamento para pacientes negros.
La FDA luego permitió
que la compañía farmacéutica
probase la eficacia en ensayos clínicos
que solo incluyeron a sujetos afroestadounidenses.
Se especuló
con que la raza actuara de intermediario para algún factor genético desconocido
que afecta la enfermedad cardíaca
o la respuesta al fármaco.
Pero piensen en el mensaje peligroso que envía:
que los cuerpos de las personas negras son tan deficientes
que un medicamento probado en ellos
no es garantía de que funcione en otros pacientes.
Al final, falló el esquema de comercialización de la farmacéutica.
Por un lado, los pacientes negros tomaron recaudos comprensibles
en usar fármacos solo para negros.
Una mujer negra de edad avanzada en una reunión de la comunidad gritó:
"¡Denme lo que toman los blancos!"
(Risas)
Y si les sorprende la medicina específica por raza,
esperen a saber
que muchos médicos en Estados Unidos
todavía usan una versión actualizada
de una herramienta de diagnóstico
desarrollada por un médico durante la esclavitud,
una herramienta de diagnóstico levemente vinculada
a justificar la esclavitud.
El Dr. Samuel Cartwright se graduó
en la Facultad de Medicina de la Universidad de Pensilvania.
Hizo prácticas en el sur profundo antes de la Guerra Civil,
y era un conocido experto en lo que entonces se llamó "medicina de negros".
Él promovió el concepto de enfermedad racial,
que las personas de distintas razas padecen enfermedades diferentes
y atraviesan enfermedades comunes de manera diferente.
Cartwright argumentaba en los años 1850
que la esclavitud era beneficiosa para las personas negras
por razones médicas.
Afirmaba que como los negros tenían menor capacidad pulmonar que los blancos,
el trabajo forzado era bueno para ellos.
Escribió en una revista médica:
"Es la vital sangre roja que se envía al cerebro
la que libera sus mentes cuando están bajo el control del blanco,
y es la falta de suficiencia de vital sangre roja
lo que encadena sus mentes a la ignorancia y la barbarie en libertad".
Para sostener esta teoría, Cartwright ayudó a perfeccionar
un dispositivo médico para medir la respiración, llamado espirómetro,
para mostrar la presunta deficiencia en los pulmones de los negros.
Hoy, los médicos todavía confirman la alegación de Cartwright
de que los negros, como raza,
tienen menor capacidad pulmonar que los blancos.
Algunos incluso usan un espirómetro modernizado
que en realidad tiene un botón con la etiqueta "raza"
para ajustar la máquina a la medición
para cada paciente, según su raza.
Es una función bien conocida llamada "corrección por raza".
El problema de la medicina racial va mucho más allá del diagnóstico erróneo.
Hace hincapié en diferencias raciales innatas en la enfermedad,
distrae la atención y los recursos
de los determinantes sociales
que causan brechas raciales atroces en la salud:
la falta de acceso a la atención médica de alta calidad;
desiertos de alimentos en los barrios pobres;
exposición a toxinas ambientales;
altas tasas de encarcelamiento;
y pasar por el estrés de la discriminación racial.
Ya ven, la raza no es una categoría biológica
que produce de manera natural estas disparidades en la salud
debido a diferencias genéticas.
La raza es una categoría social
que tiene consecuencias biológicas asombrosas,
pero debido al impacto de la inequidad social en la salud de las personas.
Y la medicina racial finge que la respuesta a estas brechas en la salud
puede encontrarse en una píldora específica para la raza.
Es mucho más fácil y mucho más lucrativo
comercializar una cura tecnológica
para estas brechas en la salud
que lidiar con las inequidades estructurales que las producen.
La razón por la que me apasiona terminar con la medicina racial
no es solo porque es mala medicina.
Estoy en esta misión
porque la forma en que los médicos practican la medicina
sigue promoviendo una visión falsa y tóxica de la humanidad.
A pesar de tantos avances visionarios que conocemos en la medicina,
hay una falta de imaginación cuando se trata de la raza.
¿Imaginarían conmigo, por un momento,
que pasaría si los médicos dejaran de tratar a los pacientes según la raza?
Supongamos que rechazaran
el sistema de clasificación del siglo XVIII
e incorporaran en su lugar el conocimiento más avanzado
de la unidad y diversidad genética humana,
que los seres humanos no entramos en categorías raciales biológicas?
¿Y si en vez de usar la raza como un intermediario crudo
de algunos factores más importantes,
los médicos en realidad investigaran y abordaran ese factor más importante?
¿Y si los médicos se sumaran a la vanguardia
de un movimiento para terminar con las desigualdades estructurales
provocadas por el racismo,
no por la diferencia genética?
La medicina racial es mala medicina,
es ciencia pobre
y es una interpretación falsa de la humanidad.
Es más urgente que nunca
abandonar finalmente este legado del pasado
y afirmar nuestra humanidad común
poniendo fin a las inequidades sociales que realmente nos dividen.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Gracias.
Gracias.